fun fact i heard you like mondays
i do like mondays catherine
i love monday so much why do you love
them
i love mondays because usually i feel
good after friday that i put everything
it organized everything so that i can
enjoy my weekends
and so come monday you know i was always
you know taught that you can always you
can always change the path of the way
you feel
and and if i feel bad about myself i can
start fresh in a monday i love my in
fact
i have something to show you i just
figured that proof would be better than
me
saying it watch this
mondays
[Music]
fun days mondays
mondays but monday's exclamation point
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
i filmed that at the beginning of the
show
because i love monday so much we as
human beings love
a new year's eve a january a birthday
we need these little calendar markers to
say
we get a clean slate and i think we get
one every monday
yeah i'm with you now when you hit
monday and you're going to the set
of this new awesome show on fox called
prodigal son
where a fellow welshman michael sheehan
is also on the show um we actually have
a clip of it i'd love to
show it too if you don't mind take a
look
oh dr capshaw not now i just have a i
said now
vivian please
don't call me that i'm sorry but i
cannot stop thinking about the other
night
neither can i it was a mistake
oh
this show is so a-list it's just
incredible it's so elevated um
are you enjoying being a part of it i am
you know coming into a show
um in the second season and people were
like why and i said well
there's a few things um i
i saw the first series and i enjoyed it
and i
watched it because my
michael sheen is from my hometown yeah
he's
he's been in my bucket list this kind of
like ever ever
gets heavier and heavier and hairy as
the days goes on bucket list bucket list
of some an actor i wanted to work with
one because he's literally from my
hometown
and drew it's like like the tiniest
pimple on the history on the
world map and our parents know each
other
and we oh you know but we'd never work
together and
we'd never met he was in the drama
department of like the
the local community and i was in the
contemporary dance compartment and
you know so it was like
why haven't we met we know so many
people that we've
since childhood since it seems to be
like 12 years old
so i wanted to work with him and the
producers pitched me this
a storyline that was just so
so much fun as an actor to get my teeth
into and then i could bring michael
sheen out of my
bucket and go i want to do that with you
it's been a lot of fun well i'm so glad
and it really shows and timing is
everything and
i'm so thrilled that you're a part of
this and that we can talk about it here
on the show
prodigal son airs tuesdays on fox
and also if you don't mind um we're
going to feature
casa zeta jones on our website because
i've been pouring through it
and it's just incredible your whole
lifestyle brand it's expanding
there's so much there already um i have
your products
and your coffee here
your website is beautiful so we're going
to throw to that as well
oh that would be wonderful because we're
all about
casa zeta jones thank you so much
and thank you catherine zeta jones
prodigal son
airs tuesday on fox and be sure to get
all of your lifestyle needs over at
casa zita jones your extraordinary
lifestyle brand
you